thank you everybody for joining us at
the H Street podcast live today our
sponsors are MV MT movement my undies
and to which prime subscribers like you
I'm just pointing to the camera there's
nobody that I can see okay don't worry I
just like to watch you okay you like a
son that I never had as your husband and
wife nobody's people know that it's yes
okay good it's kind of our like you're
not just using that as a way to get
swingers and stuff I do
oh we're husband and wife oh yeah sorry
next week Sean Evans you know him yeah I
was about once - he's our mutual enemy
he is he's I thought he was just
fantastic yeah it was one of the most
fun things I've ever done because what
an odd way to do an interview it's real
it used to be this conversation right
well yeah and in today's world you got
to step it up talking's not enough
anymore well and there is a universality
and wings easy if you don't eat chicken
what's one thing but I I went as far as
I could go did you go the distance yeah
you did you were you drinking milk I was
chugging milk I had no I didn't feel bad
about the milk right I was hiccupping no
I know I only drink breastfed milk and
fry my own hey I like it when you're my
age you just man boobs just start
lactating milk just starts dribbling out
of there's two pour and some of us look
forward to leakage well Sean Evans is on
next week so if you want to leave
questions for him there on the subreddit
please do Bob Saget doesn't really need
an introduction but I'm gonna do it for
you anyway because that's the format of
the show television host actor comedian
Bob Saget I don't need an introduction
let me just say this you've got a new
special out on Amazon called
zero-to-sixty
yes it's not it's just cool I'm excited
about it and it's a great by the way
okay so now I'm gonna shut up keep going
it was
laughs a riot a gag a goof
it was meant to be entertaining and it
was meant to be kind of where I'm at
right now
right and I got the I'm on my way to
getting serious which doesn't mean I'm
not gonna be funny but like talking
about my mom passing away and stuff like
that it seems to be creeping more into
my reality of of just human existence
rather than talking about politics and
and I do like to talk about my penis but
yeah there oh well guys rest assured
there's plenty of penis jokes it's a
drinking game yes not not alcohol I'm
just saying that my penis it's a
drinking game that is that rude can we
say that on here well we were just
calling my literal wife my bottom [ __ ]
I don't write in I jump right into
defend her I was wrong you don't know
her I'm married to her no but I could
tell right away that she doesn't deserve
to be on the bottom she deserves okay
she's on a no space is good I don't
think it's a [ __ ] anymore man I'm just
saying I don't think we can we can't I
just think it's it is not the time it is
a time of all good men to to find out so
top [ __ ] that'd be a good show for like
Fox some you know top [ __ ] tonight on
top is right like a pimp and prostitute
reality show like you can hold it down
and keep the other hos and I keep the
other up you know hold it down and keep
it up that to me then you're not
offending everybody cuz the show itself
is offensive so it cancels itself out
you're not politically upsetting people
you're not gonna offend pimps and hoes
yes you are they get hurt that's pimps
and hoes be hitting and slapping man
right you're true that's true my special
was I love the title 0-60 which
commemorates you turning 60 years old
yes
how has your sense of comedy changed now
from back when you know you were mr.
aristocrats right now aristocrats
couldn't be done now
that is something that movie maybe it
would come out right now as an anti you
know freedom of speech fashion it was
just funny and weird and wild but today
and it will be like a statement and what
but that's what it was it was it with
the Penn Jillette and pop Avanza who
directed it made it took four years and
filmed 100 comedians telling the same
joke that I'd only heard twice in my
life and the point was a censorship
different ways the people can do an art
form you know all tell the same thing
everybody paint the same painting and
let's see what happens but it really was
about freedom of speech I mean Lenny
Bruce went to jail for saying things
that were said oh we in that film that's
interesting because it's gotten so much
worse since then oh yeah I couldn't even
well for people who don't know because a
lot of our audience are a little on the
younger side as they should be yes and
they are the future yes literally I mean
literally yeah we're out of here one way
it's not like we're gonna save the
planet it's like we're getting the hell
out of here and leading it to not just
blame what aristocrats to the people who
don't know what it is to Kratz was a
documentary made by Penn Jillette famed
entertainer as smart does magic but in a
revealing way Paul Provenza who I'd
known since I was 19 years old who was a
stand-up comedian is a stand-up comedian
and director and they worked for years
interviewing a hundred comedians and
George Carlin the great George Carlin
know any Millennials listening sorry I
didn't mean to label you or foster
objectify you well it is cuz I'm 60 but
I'm 61 really now cuz the special
happened and then I turned 61 so that's
weird but but I'm not saying Millennials
derogatorily basically I'm saying I'm
three times your age so I'm the one
eating it you know but it was really
about an old joke that was an inside
joke kinda but it really wasn't a joke
and now I won't tell it on here cuz
there's no purpose but the premise of
the joke was a family that's so
desperate to make it in show business
they go into an agent's office and he's
what do you do for a living and they say
what do we do and there's a million ways
to tell it it's like jazz you can go off
and tell it any way you want but the
family is somehow nude and committing
unspeakable acts and then at the very
end when they're all finished with all
these unspeakable acts and and
everything up to that point is jazz it's
how do you want to tell it how gross you
want to be Ruth some awful despicable or
what some people told it much cleaner
and it's a sweet little hey they did a
couple of somersaults and a few people
like Don Rickles and Chris Rock they
said I'm not telling this you know Jerry
Seinfeld I don't do that joke you know
they're right for them and I respect
that yeah and I miss Don Rickles you
guys got to look him up immediately I
wanted to talk to you about I'm here I'm
here and I don't want to leave so so at
the end of the bit they finish they go
tada and the agent says what do you call
yourselves and they go the foul whoever
you choose in the family goes the
aristocrats I think it was my version it
was someone's dying breath it was the
last thing but no I couldn't finish I
couldn't finish the punchline because I
was on stage at the Laugh Factory so I
literally as I was about to say the
aristocrats had to go onstage the joke
was and George Carlin who was one of the
greatest stand-ups there any you ever
have had as well-phrased said don't tell
this this is not for public consumption
this is for behind the alley this is for
how raw can you go and the point was to
make other comics laugh I guess or to
make just go three form absurd right and
it's a good way to play it's improv if
you take out the filth and there's a
million ways to do brilliant stuff that
people do I mean you watch a lot of the
television that's on now that we like
you know you watch it one of the good
improv ish type shows on Comedy Central
or you watch something where you
watching Will Ferrell movie where things
that is cooking and you know they're
making it up as you're watching it and
that's that's that you know but this was
a different animal so years was the end
the most infamous one everyone
cause like a man Gonzaga and his
aristocrats bit we can't even well when
I opened up you mean that when I open up
Newsweek and I realize there was never
an amage to full houses character right
but to this and it was the flip well how
do you feel about that I feel good I
mean I I do many different things I've
been on Broadway a bunch of times and
not the street have actually been in
place well and and n Street yeah and I
just I love acting I love directing I
love doing different stuff but you know
you get pegged to something and I played
Danny Tanner and damn and I'm gonna play
prop it's for the rest of my life
because it's not going anywhere so that
shows we're gonna go do more fuller
houses that house will remain full for
eternity it's it's not possible by the
way if you go and see the real house in
San Francisco which I did
it's about 2,500 square feet oh that's
small and that is full and it was bought
by the original executive producer
creator Jeff Franklin and I think it's
just to say hey you want to see uncle
Jesse's room you know but it's it's a
small house but when you walk into the
distal living room you know you're
looking at a 7,000 square foot house if
you're at the set so it's it's an Alice
in Wonderland and a world once you go
through the Tanner door so I do you know
that's just that's something I get to do
that I think is fun and then I've got
all those other stuff I'm doing but I
love I I'm sure you've had a ton of
stand-ups on here are you standing up no
no I'm uh you're on the fringe we don't
know you know it's like it's it's new
media right I'm a youtuber whatever that
means but we had like our first live
show last week and it did have I did
have a very performance-based feel to it
right working and watch these cameras
and it's a live show
we're live right now yeah and so I mean
I definitely want to consider myself a
stand-up comedian because I have a lot
of respect for what they do and I don't
do that I don't wreck jokes and I don't
prep and I don't have an act so well
then they do you similar to some
stand-up comedians I would say this is
where we're at is the next stage of
broadcasting is where we're at you know
there were there were three networks and
people would look into the camera and
oh my god that guy's a genius you know
oh boy Johnny Carson holy crap he said
that and it was a way of looking into
the camera communicating with one person
or communicating with thousands of
people right and and that's what you're
doing here you got millions of people
you got you have an earth that can
listen to you whereas other ievel didn't
so that's a responsibility by the way
yeah you can't be putting [ __ ] on the
bottom I mean this is it's it's a
misnomer it's very complicated are you
careful because there might be as you're
doing this there's so many people
watching this right oh you guys watching
you're all and I again bottom [ __ ] is
very complimentary it is it's a but yes
it's the okay saying it's like me saying
man that was sick man that was bad
you're Atlas you have the world on your
shoulders you're the bottom [ __ ] that
the world is oh why didn't you say that
I wouldn't amazing five minutes Adam oh
you just made it up I just conceptually
because there is also the implication
that she's being used so no Ian can you
do do some research on bottom [ __ ] back
there well this this is kind of big I
know there's an old song B bottom girls
but that they make the rock and world go
round but that ain't this do it they may
be what I'm suggesting to you and I
didn't get to get it out cuz we're never
gonna get to one question cuz I know
it's good which means yeah this is good
it's good you're a good host
you're both great hosts and I'm a
mediocre thank you but the truth of it
is someone right now is watching this
and they are the bottom [ __ ] now they
could be male or female or an animal and
they are the bottom of a pile of other
entities whether they be mammals or a
man or a woman
there could be nine people stacked like
a deck of cards right now and the one on
the very bottom is the bottom [ __ ] in
the negative vernacular right and there
they could be very upset by this or go
you know what I'm gonna crawl out from
the bottom and they're gonna get out of
that pile and that you would in that way
you've helped them this fired I'm
feeling so many
no I ain't going right don't cry you
hold those tears back but if you need to
cry you know I'm the damn bottom [ __ ]
for so long and I hear you see right now
it comes out it was not a high I sweat
Annapolis it's not at but it's your top
[ __ ] you see you want to work alright I
think we got to get rid of the words
[ __ ] yeah I don't think I think that's
the issue let's scratch the whole head
scratched bit and probably say you've
watched the latest Chappelle special he
talks about it and the way he talks
about it it's like the bottom [ __ ] is
the person who's like carrying
everything doing everything without them
you wouldn't be anything but you're also
using them yeah now then you explained
it and I should have see I didn't i
watched half of it I did not see that
part yet he's probably the best living
sander a median so great that exists but
I think she's proven her point what's
gonna turn into one what are you again
let's go back to my prostitute - that's
mine mine is a different kind of special
right cuz it's it's more I'm trying to
entertain people in kind of an
old-school way right with stories and
then I have comedy music yeah
which I've always done and that I was
gonna say before any of this happened it
would be a great edit to lift everything
out of no bottom bits in this whole
thing is that I feel a stronger need
more than ever to make people feel good
to entertain me because I know I'm back
to how you were different now
then you exactly that was your question
and when I started you know you want to
get on TV there's people that are
watching that want to be stars that want
to be famous and that ain't no reason to
get into showbiz YouTube that's really
become a thing and that's reality stars
and that that before YouTube you had
your reality star that was the the next
offspring of television and all it well
anybody wants us to be famous and and
and the point is you want you want to do
a good show right now you you know I I
want to be good on your show you know
I'm not doing this
somebody'll know who I am is this a
result
of maturity or something else I think
it's a lot of things but maturity is
part of it I think it's a lot of life
experience that's been but prioritize
things I have you know three daughters I
have a fiance who actually loves me yeah
and I know it was during your special
you were not engaged right because I
mean no I got engaged right a girlfriend
yeah we were gonna go back and and just
loop in a TR fiance boy I sure love my
fiance but I and so I have a huge
respect with with all my comedy which
tends to go r-rated and has if you go
through my old stuff man I mean I I'm
gonna like whoa there's pedophile jokes
in there and I sure I bet I'm if you do
it with the sound off it doesn't look
like I mean any harm
you know but it but it's offensive some
of it and there's still ways to do it in
Dave Chappelle in that special would
bring up and it's it's his style and
it's what a great stand-up comedian like
himself you throw something in you throw
in the grenade that's gonna upset people
but you finesse it he tells as you go in
and then you get out of it so there's a
smoothing that happens which is
basically called intelligent
communication it's smart conversation if
there's something you have an argument
with somebody and you need to get the
point out you you tee it up really well
you get your point out you listen to
them what you really have to do and then
we'll be right back therapy session but
but also my maturity cuz you know hey
man I'm 61 yeah
but I don't feel it and I don't I don't
act it and but I'm responsible I take
care of a lot of people I take care of
strangers I mean it if something
happened on a plane do you want me on
that plane I get mad I'm saying if
somebody just sit there while a
stewardess is gonna grab you from you
sit and injure you or recently did you
about the story of the puppy that was
stowed in the overhead I heard
so hair and and you know any injustice
but I was even talking more about I was
talking about more secure I am stupid
enough to think that I'm a hero you know
I have an adrenaline that kicks in if
something's wrong and they're feeling it
justice I want to test with fake Uzis
is not the time for that see the world
is so fragile but I if I see something
weird I will report it I will go and I
will get help you're a good citizen I
want to do citizen's arrest
I don't think that exists anymore well
then you could just arrest it sound more
like a vigil on me if I'm being honest
I'm just looking for anyone to a citizen
around I will tell you this I have three
kids you guys do not have kids yet right
do you want have kids we have a puppy
which is pretty much like our baby Musa
test there's a lot of people I think
where we have a lot of love for this
puppy and I think we're ready to get
more takes him out and wakes up in the
morning so I feel like that's kind of
that'sthat's the good relationship
you're being a good you're being a good
man you're being a great bottom and wait
for somebody and let me tell you I
cannot wait citizen's arrest my first
person it'd be pretty cool doing there
are no there's people sadly exposing
themselves that's a citizen's arrest but
I don't think you want to do it yourself
you want to call a cop I'll first show
it then arrest myself we have to be
that's it that's the end of my specials
that song we got to be kind to each
other that's what I that's the
difference in what I'm doing now I know
why I'm a stand-up for a lot of years I
went I want to direct I directed six
movies I just finished one which I'd
like to talk about at some point because
I'm a [ __ ] and I look plug everything I
can and that's what a [ __ ] does
everything she can that's how she made
he sorry he I don't want to be your
strength how many be a gigolo I mean I
am a gigolo yeah yeah opportunity yeah I
wonder if pimps have both men and female
or if they're female pimps whoo yeah as
a male prostitute I think
there's different I think there's
definitely male prostitutes and I
believe I know they are gotta be a great
female pimp so we're saying you're out
to get your own Private Idaho and goes
it was a male prostitute a [ __ ] and
anybody can be be a [ __ ] and a [ __ ]
can be a positive or negative a pair
yeah of course what I learned here my
[ __ ] Biggie Smalls one of my favorite
song Deerman for a girlfriend
whoo yeah anyway now let me ask you
that's accurate how how is Fame affected
you you've been famous for a long long
time right how has what's your
relationship with Fame been like over
the years from kind of when you first
became famous from a normal dude people
recognized on the street to now having
been famous for a long long time right
how was your relationship with Fame
choice becomes part of your life and to
hate your life is foolish so you adjust
yourself and your psyche as long as
someone's not violating your time with
your family that's important or you know
if you're having an emotional experience
with somebody you don't want somebody
coming over for a selfie sure you know
yeah but if I'm going through an airport
that's right a regular commercial
airport and there's a lot of selfies
that happen if they see me because I
live like Big Bird I'm 64 I look like
the guy on full house and so I want to
I'm I'm fast I learn to take a fast
selfie and get a lot of Purell because
you know their phone has been in bad
place phones any measure of the [ __ ]
that I know is on my phone is there [ __ ]
on actual I mean it's part of an actual
poopoo yeah it's possible I mean I'm not
saying that I [ __ ] on my way to say like
what is she I'm just saying particle but
no that [ __ ] part of particles they say
they would take toothbrushes if you
believe your toothbrush next to the
toilet scientists crunch the numbers on
that toothbrush well I saw that problem
I wipe with my toothbrush give it to my
grandmother
man she's dead so it's okay I don't want
to offend anybody you how do you really
technically well no I wouldn't ever no I
don't think the soul should particle
thing then you try to get out because it
seems like you're wrong about 60% of the
time yeah no that's fine
but no if you're doubting the [ __ ]
particle I'm sorry I'm gonna have to no
I don't doubt the [ __ ] part it over
because I'm rep a couple of my agents or
[ __ ] particles and I keep them around
yeah but I'm just I'm simply agreeing
that people's phones is are don't touch
you don't do not touch other people's
phones and I do keep the Purell and I
try to extend it even further don't
touch other people well I I kind of
agree with that right and and you know
you get you can get the point is you if
you travel a lot like I do you end up
getting sick and that is docket
particles that's just being on playing
breathing people's air [ __ ] particles in
there you just got that [ __ ] particle
thing it's the particle that makes it
humorous yeah because it's like
scientific but all sudden it's like no
longer like an atom or something for
research it's just a little piece of
[ __ ] it's actually the last thing
Stephen Hawking was working mankind
cannot exist on earth and we must be
careful to stay out late and [ __ ]
articles oh here we go I got some
research article fact a 2012 study by
Manchester University in England says
it's much worse more than 10 times
million bacteria call your tooth wait
this is weirded weirdly but essentially
10 million bacteria call your toothbrush
home what I have to say like that just
tell me it's all in the tooth there are
we understand that at all yeah I'm
trying to make basically they're sterile
by the way so that's so that's what I'm
told what Aaron is sterile I'm so you
can't get that you were saying I'm I'm
sterile no I was like man
you're in I'm ever in there on that go
in the bottom inch club peepee I'll talk
to you in terms you understand yes I'm
young peepees sterile poopoo is [ __ ]
particles right and so that it's
interesting what the human body does to
whatever I think we should move to
another topic no she found some great
information
I don't know I don't like bathroom humor
that much I found in three of my finally
discovered do you follow
again like we come from very different
worlds of it won't wait enter say that
we come from different worlds of my
medium in your medium were you I don't
tradition at all really well your
especially is actually on Amazon Prime
which is pretty new yeah but like we
know we found our audience on YouTube
which is that I was at the beginning of
Nakano you're right but as a video show
if you want to see people get hit in the
nuts I was the I call myself the Gateway
you had to go through me it is a guy
falling in a manhole and doesn't get out
is he dead
that was a video that I would run and be
objecting the whole time because I want
to see him climb out of the manhole
right these days no one cares if the guy
falls on a manhole he's gone no but it
travels it what did you curate those
videos at all were you involved in I was
I was I was involved with killing some
that would drive me crazy but I narrated
them all with my bad voices look at me
I'm so mean you know that and it was
basically I was just copying a little
Jerry Lewis and Mel Blanc who is this
guy that everybody should know because
he did all the voices of all the Warner
Brothers cartoons which means Bugs Bunny
Sylvester Tweety Bird okay all the
Marvin the Martian that's Mel Blanc so I
was doing a poor man's imitation of him
with a show a video show that became the
number one show in the world for a while
oh yeah I mean I was when I was a kid
and I was watching it all the time that
was my favorite show so we didn't have
this right and this you're doing
something that in five years you to the
two of you will
probably be in a place that you won't
even believe that you're at you can you
believe we just sold our company yeah
what show do we want to do it's and you
go into this new media I mean Howard
Stern certainly changed things get
around and made serious what it is sure
he's the jewel in the crown over there
and then I go over there and I love
going over there I see a lot of people I
know that are friends and I'll go on the
shows and that that's the bridge between
you know generational broadcasting yeah
of three radio and but this is different
I mean this is a they got this this
doesn't go away and that scares me
well the the process of coming up like
on YouTube is just like a free-for-all
and almost it's so hard to rise above
like if you're a [ __ ] particle and a sea
of you know a lot of other [ __ ]
particles it's hard to rise above but
the mechanism of when you gain Fame when
you were coming up I was still on the
circuit right I was 10 years trying to
get a job yeah you know I started at 17
years old I just played terrible places
that was how you did it back then yeah I
played [ __ ] holes when that just meant a
bad club not a country you don't want to
go to right yeah and and you know most
of them were in Ohio but no I was there
but but yeah there's a bottom line is
this all exists because people feel very
alone and they need to have something
communicating with them and they don't
want the quiet or to read a book or and
I'm not being derogatory about it cuz we
all get lonely
my fiance's out of town I'm pretty
lonely my hands broken it's been a rough
week yeah closed it in a drawer okay
yeah putting the loop back exhausting
but I you know you're people watching
right now you're the reason this show is
happening the reason that it's going to
multiply that's that's what happens to
these this stuff catches fire and all of
a sudden it's like whoa how did that
he's
14 million followers we must give him a
movie and we're gonna see more of it you
know anybody that's talented and this
isn't about becoming famous anybody that
has a vision to do something and does it
can attain whether they're happy or not
themselves can attain mass consumption I
guess the difference are there seems
like it's a good point though whether
they're happy or not because it's
completely unrelated to implead
unrelated a lot of people if you host it
you know I haven't of course know the
late-night talk shows because I'm 140 so
I know everybody didn't it doesn't and
it's a hard job and and it's it's it's a
great job it's like it's this crazy
thing I mean I was doing the video show
we were doing 30 shows a year and I was
part complaining because that was my
nature and I was stupid and I was 30 and
I was good and then I was part like oh
my god I'm king of the world this is
amazing that's number one
yeah of course and I was getting paid
and you were doing full house at the
same time yes I was my mind I was right
in the video had my writers come to the
dressing room a full house but my
requirements at Full House were like Oh
Michelle you can't bring a horse in the
living room and then I go back upstairs
and then ironically it would be a video
about a horse sitting on a man you know
so it all type interesting but but I
still like doing entertainment that
doesn't have to have f-bombs in it and
talk about my penis
although I think that probably my
favorite song here it doesn't hurt
anybody else right and and it's not
really that offensive no no not really
you know what I I grew up in Israel and
full house is like a classic even there
so it's just funny I was a guest of the
Ministry of Tourism of Israel and it was
in 1989 and I took my parents and I got
off an El Al flight the first two plane
lands and as a camel that says Israel
loves Bob Saget really I'm gonna gamble
I can't
the whole plains looking at this and I
was so embarrassed camel was on the
runway on the run you know that's why
why would they want to and like down
like downplay or a publicity stunt they
used it for the it wasn't a jerusalem
post it was more of the like the New
York Post type of paper in res real yeah
but I I had you know a remarkable uh
trip obviously and it was a time where
you could go to the Dome of the rock it
was a time where the world was a little
bit easier even though it's never been
easy I said do you miss it
yeah I always especially my family is
the main thing mmm yummy to talk to them
yeah we do last year we went twice go
back every year but it's like you I
lived there for five years you lived
there were you in the army
yeah you have to be like a god oh I love
her married Wonder Woman thank you you
take this bottom bit stuff right out of
the vernacular no it's a it's it's a
it's a mystical interesting place and
it's so weird that so many religions are
all it's the bedrock of so many of them
and that we are in a Tower of Babel as
humanity it's such a tiny country and
there's like it's like everything is
happening right there I don't know it's
like New Jersey and Delaware fighting
with it because it's really not that
special of a plot of land if you take
the biblical but they made that right
yeah your architecture of what they made
out is also impossible but it was built
a lot of it was built by slaves I mean
that you know the Wailing Wall was built
by slaves I mean I would imagine right
well that's been a while everything
large and monolithic all the churches in
Europe are built by slaves yes 50 years
old I mean there's really just a bunch
of Hut's there before like Eli's
pictures her family is they grew up
there
but they have pictures from like the 50s
when Israel was first established after
World War Two and Tel Aviv which is now
the major metropolis there was just
since then was literally just handle
been more than 50 years now it's more
than 50 or it's not five years ago now
it's a years ago and it was the greenest
desert I ever saw you know in 48 not
that I do know that it's poor yeah yeah
you're right
you're kind of both right it's a wedding
it's my fault well I'm choosing her side
yeah would you expect me to do I'm DJ's
by mission right DJ Steph Michelle is
dad when I'm gonna choose you Mike Steve
yeah so I'm on a plane Bill Maher and I
did the Hawaii show right which he does
all every year and he asked me to do it
because we've known each other a long
time and we wanted to have fun and I
wanted to go so that was a parody of
that the Franken unfortunate out Franken
thing so on a serious note photos like
these days can actually offend people
and get people into trouble and
understandably and and well I'm
wondering what do you think about this
like cult of outrage that we're living
today as a comedian is there how do you
how do you feel about everyone getting
so angry well it's hard for me if
someone's hurt for real reasons are you
sick you keep quiet acid reflux oh you
do yeah do you take prilosec ID like to
[ __ ] heat it like candy okay look
right in the camera and do an ad for
those not helping they're gonna send you
a cake the worst
you'll get a free case of prilosec I
have a lifetime supply right it's
clearly not how about I'm a horrible hey
take prilosec what happened you know
some people were outraged by it and Bill
and I talked about it and he was like
people it's a joke it's a joke and it's
a satire of something really unfortunate
but because I know I
I'm a huge fan I always impolite to Al
Franken he made mistakes obvious
mistakes he admitted to them but it's
still you know there's so many mistakes
out there and there's so many people
that have violated so many people but
that was coming out of an animal house
time but no matter what you do no matter
who you are the biggest thing is don't
shove your tongue down anybody's mouth
yeah grab them physically touch them I
believe the hands in that picture and in
Al's picture aren't actually on the
actual brain they are a distance away
yeah it's still making fun of someone
but if you were doing other stuff that's
another bomb or more specifically I hear
a lot from stand-up comedians they're
like I don't go to universities anymore
because I can't say anything you do I do
your experience well I I just I just
think everybody's wrong I think that you
know your left your right you're liberal
you're conservative I just think there's
a comment I want to find the common bond
and I believe that humor is one of the
ways and music does it to have always
done comedy songs because I used to be a
fan of Martin Mull I'm actually gonna
make a documentary about him which is
happening right have to I had to get to
work but he's a guy that you you would
know him a brilliant comedian and he did
comedy songs and they kind of a
foolproof in a way and so you find humor
that's foolproof if something's really
really funny I mean if you're watching
Eddie Murphy and Nutty Professor or in
the Klumps um you show that to the whole
world I mean pretty much yeah people
aren't gonna fight over know you're
hurting my feelings
yeah it's just watching a genius do so
the hilarious yeah so I don't know eh I
believe there has to be some common bond
that can stop all this insanity but
there also has to be the good part about
it all is that people have to that
there's too much abuse period and
there's too much it's enough but and we
have to we have to just police human
dignity
besides police all the tragedies and
when a tragedy strikes and I'm I'm
on that night when a comedian is about
to do a show Wow what is that like it is
a well you see the late night guys the
late night guys dresses it's like they
do they're seven minutes but we're gonna
do whatever when 9/11 happened David
Letterman had no studio audience and did
his shows interesting he just did them
he and he he just said we're gonna do
these shows and they would have
conversations and that's broadcasting
just and that's compactly there to be
there for people when they need it and
that's the whole deal yeah it is - and
somehow raise everybody up not to quote
Josh Groban but right who I like he sang
a song you raised me up you know Josh
Groban I'm not familiar with that song
it's a famous song because people would
know it but I just did a I played
someone diabolical I've had a talk show
host accused of killing his assistant on
a show called the good cop with Tony
Danza and Josh Groban on Netflix which
is coming out soon nice I decided to be
nice to stop all this talk of making the
world a better place and plug something
certainly did you so you so merged you
have merged it goes with us well we've
got shirts we've got well ela owns a
fashion company Neil is the CEO we have
we have our merch which is like t-shirts
with stuff you know and like this cop
yeah I love the Simpsons a little bit it
has that kind of feel yeah we have merch
like we have our HTH reproductions which
is our main comedy channel and this is
kind of offshoot so it's a free podcast
but most of the merchants t-shirts and I
also recently started a clothing line
really merch stuff that you designed
yeah yeah wow that's a G so what are you
doing I do pretty might have a kid
you're walking the dog taking in the
next level yeah you guys having a kid
would be nice if you want you
in the world of the pair don't want to
where we do yeah you are is okay to tell
me this I mean I you know ela oh it does
guys already got the bad joke you know
merch speaking of plugs don't I were you
yes go to a commercial break
don't go anywhere because there's tons
of goofs and laughs and spoofs and what
what's what are you selling in this
commercial right good stuff
oh man that niced stuff not jars of [ __ ]
particles well I think I mean having
tested I don't know if that okay
everybody's yelling is it my particles
or would it be like a communal of
particles these are all your it's a
flavor it's a mix it's all end on an
airplane it's a blend it's like a jar
some air from airplane and here's a jar
a sparkly jar off of an airplane and
someone comes at you in an alley and
intervention depending on what did you
use how did you take me down I use just
the hand airplane for blame damn so that
would be in our next episode
but until then these are our sponsors
and I hope that you'll support them stay
tuned thank you too and VM T for
sponsoring this episode the HP podcast
movement watches you guys have heard us
talk right here they were made by two
college dropouts that started their own
wash company with the belief that
fashion didn't have to break the bank
and they've now sold over 2 million
watches in 160 countries and I don't
know if you've checked out their site
lately but they've doubled the number of
styles and they're still expanding check
out this watch sleek beautiful
fashionable sexy as hell and I think
they'll probably even stop a bullet how
thick and meaty this thing is tactical
although I don't recommend trying it
they've also started making
bracelets look house looking amazing
those are the packaging unbelievable
you buy that for your significant other
all I have to say forget about it I
don't know if that means but they're
gonna be freaking stoked if you get that
thank you
eula they look great on you by the way
let me show you my favorite one it opens
and closes so easily
woo love it guys this watch starts at
just 95 dollars if you were to go to a
department store you're looking at four
to five hundred dollars easy for a
tactical beautiful handsome watch like
this forget it dude they figured out
that by selling online they were able to
cut out the middleman with all of his BS
markup and provide the best possible
price okay
it's a classic design quality
construction and styled minimalist leave
because they know the Year tasteful dude
who just wants mentalistic beautiful
watch so here's the deal guys get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to MVM t.com / h3c wide
movement keeps growing check out their
expanding collection go to nvm t.com
slash h3 and join the flippin movement
my dudes thank you to sponsoring us
movement next up me undies thanking me
undies guys me on DS you know I'm a huge
believer in their product they're the
perfect balance of comfortable fit every
month they have new and exciting prints
and they arrive at your door in a fun
bag a fun bag it sounds like good
matches Dino it just sounds like a
little sexual a little fun max good to
play with your fun bags around look at
this you wearing but like the point is
that you can give yourself a mega wedgie
and still be comfortable
that's how flexible and breathable and
beautiful these Monday me undies
underwears are give me a minute as I I
don't I do want to have kids someday
these are covering oh yeah I want to
have kids relatively soon so let me just
fix myself here me undies uses lensing
micro modal and our underwear it's a
sustainably sourced naturally soft fiber
that starts with beech wood trees and
ends with the most amazing fabric you've
ever experienced the results are
downright dreamy
I don't know what the rest of this copy
says but I literally just atomic wedgie
myself and I'm fine how flexible and
soft and breathable can I get it started
as Beachwood tree and it ended up in
between my [ __ ] balls and anus isn't
life beautiful the roads that you take
you just never know me n DS has
adventurous prints and designs
adventurous they can end up in my
[ __ ] that's so adventurous they're a
[Laughter]
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
me on dude
guarantee we love their undies or your
money back 100% satisfaction guarantee
you got nothing to lose guys you get
your money back if you don't like it and
you can give it the atomic wedgie test
yourself and see it doesn't even hurt it
doesn't feel bad at all you don't have
to do that so here's the deal mandis has
a great offer for our listeners for any
first-time purchase when you purchase me
on DS you get 20% off 20% off and free
shipping
mandis is so sure you're gonna love it
you have a 100% satisfaction guarantee
if you don't love your first pair you
get a full refund
that's the deal guys it's it's it's a
it's a no-brainer
oh it says there it's a no-brainer it's
a no-brainer get 20% off your first pair
of the most comfortable undies you will
ever put all up and put over your head
to get 20% off your first pair free
shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guaranteed go to Mandy's
comm slash h3 that's me Andy's comm
slash h3 guys if you are in the market
for a watch or a bracelet or on
we're soft beautiful whatever is please
consider supporting our sponsors to help
support the show with that being said
let's get right back into it thank you
and welcome back
we're here with Bob Saget I would wanted
to ask you please you well here I showed
the picture with you of Bill Maher yeah
you were in Hawaii yeah and as I
understand
Bill Maher was talking that he was in
Hawaii during the missile warning air
we're doing I don't know I think he
stayed longer I was not is that I missed
that but I've been through you know I
lived four blocks from where we are
right now where we're where we are and
so I went to school at Birmingham High
and I lived you don't want people know
where we are right now I think it's had
I not the exact location no no I would
never give that but I looked out the
window and I was kid in 1971 I was like
13 14 and everybody else was not born
it's listening and the ground was an
earthquake that was a seven point one
and the ground was like waves
it was just Ross the Northridge one it
was it was so I was in Ventura at the
time and that really shook me there too
yeah and that was not as bad as no we're
not even close and they marked it down
from a seven point one to a six point
eight or something really yeah I said
that was well that's not a missile
attack but it's also pretty harrowing no
it is it is yeah it's not a missile yeah
well we're on in any case you don't want
to be getting a vasectomy door either
have you gotten a vasectomy I can't
discuss that you'll have to look into my
penis and tell me kaleidoscope right
many colors that's how I lure people um
like it's in you here Prince music right
I hate music wired into my testicles
that's very modern of you it was two
discs it's a disco Wow what can Adam
people in the other room are gone home
they're great they're terrific crowd
great they're actually wonderful and let
me ask you about Don Rickles yeah yeah
again I think he's such a classic
such a staple and young people on your
how old are you I'm 32 and so you know
and Don Rickles is because of David
Letterman putting him on Jimmy Kimmel
can hang amage to him and Jimmy is is
boy one of the love is a friend and one
of the sweetest people that exists yeah
I love you and n is and he is so
compassionate I I'm gonna vivisect off
at the wrinkles for a quarter of a
second I do a benefit every year for the
scleroderma Research Foundation which is
a disease that hits mostly women I lost
a sister to the disease and Jimmy's done
the auction several times flow Wow and
he is a guy that use it you email and he
let me give his email on he is a guy
that his I mean you can see what
happened with the son Billy yeah how he
cares and he's just a lovely lovely man
and he loved on equally I saw him
cracking up we were all losing it and
Don I became very close to done to
Stamos John Stamos introduced me to him
but I had directed Don in a movie called
dirty work Norma chrono article I love
that movie but your I wish I'm one of
the only ones yeah now me and my friends
when we were younger call them GM really
still love well now I think it gets the
respect that it deserves it does its
marinate a little bit it's a it's become
a goes made for 15 year old boys and now
new boys are thrown our demographic Dan
yeah yeah so these talk we dorm and I
are talking because all I'm saying is
norm and I are talking
but anyway talking I love what's in mom
what's in store is one of the funniest
people alive back to Don Rickles yeah
Don Rickles is this guy who we won't see
again who was able to take what came out
of the 40s and 50s of racism mmm and and
really doing things you can't do and
objectifying people and but it wasn't
done was love it was all I love those
unbelievable not
how he did it still to this day it was
because the love and the energy was so
strong and you wanted to be insulted by
him he turned himself he was such an
icon and he works by the way here's the
other key and you'll find this out the
longer you do this thing or whatever you
guys parlay into parlay I say that like
every day of course he doesn't say
parlay yeah part of Aging yeah I'm gonna
parlay back into the story you know he
he just wanted to he came out of that he
did three shows in Vegas starting at
2:00 in the morning so he was in the
trenches I was in the trenches in my own
way I was working in terrible places
just like everybody tonight I'm you know
is is out in this town we're in Los
Angeles and a lot of open mikes and a
lot of places trying to get time to
become good to learn and then people
that Revere comedy want to be good and
that's like people that I have the most
respect for that are going through it
right now
and it doesn't end you're always
auditioning for something you know but
Don it's definable when you watch on
YouTube watched a Letterman with Denzel
Washington on it so and Don kept saying
I can't believe he stayed for all my
segments because so it stands out for
three segments I believe and then Don
comes on but Denzel one of the stay for
everybody and then Don would turn to
Denzel and say could you get my car or
because he knew that it's the last thing
and then he axons mine yeah
what it was was saying isn't this racism
just a big bunch of [ __ ] yeah it
wasn't it had no hatred or animosity it
was literally the opposite cuz if you're
a comedian and in you're working in
clubs and in Vegas you're with very few
white people and that's where I want to
be very few white people that's it my
clients down here lots of white people
here it is very white
there's one thing I notice about the a
treat podcast oh thank you very much
we're about to get articles written we
have not had a oh my god yeah yeah I'm
big trouble you guys got to do some
stuff here you gonna fire about three
people change the subject
what cuz Don Rickles is the kind of guy
when you see him he's always on he is on
like on on yeah well you were friends
with the guy so what was he like when he
wasn't on or was he almost comedians
that I've known and know they can be
funny we like to screw around with each
other and and just see who's gonna say
something that's gonna be crazy or and
it's sparring you know but that wasn't
Don he he would get pretty serious you'd
have dinner with him really I'm he'd
have a cocktail and you'd sit there and
he would hear we get very serious I mean
he lost his son Oh at 43 years old his
son passed away and just a few years ago
his daughters are really good comedian
Mindy Mindy Rickles and she looks like
him which is and I have three daughters
and my middle one looks like me and I'm
like well wait a sec but she's really
pretty soon as that mean am i attractive
[ __ ] particles right I'll look up you if
you've wanted to say I'm not going to
use that crass language but if you put
here listen to you how the times have
changed well no I'm sayin I will not use
up that they say I will [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of you that's just easy well it's
not funny it's also the basis of what I
would do maybe 20 years ago but I don't
I never used the word [ __ ] as a verb I
that's not true either but anyway [ __ ]
out of somebody anyway how attractive is
that that's not that's you don't want to
break that down well no no yeah you're
like a mess you know your toothbrush is
ruined I will [ __ ] you tenderly and the
[ __ ] will not be expelled from your body
and if a little does seep out a little
bit I'll clean it up let me explain
something to you right now you just [ __ ]
block yourself from having a baby for
two months
if I can get into your chances are we
worth it if I was her I would duct-tape
my underwear on the night I would not
allow you near me Bob let me ask you
this I don't want to see you like that I
apologize I just duct-taped your wife's
underwear what do you have to say about
the allegations that you raped and
murdered a girl in 1990
well that was Gilbert Godfried and what
happens is we're at a time right now
that that is from the roast when Comedy
Central Roast of me and and I was happy
to be roasted on there because it was my
friends which most of the roasts are not
your friends there's people that you
know somebody will be honest nobody
knows anybody at that point right here's
some guy who never made me come talk
[ __ ] about you right so I had Stamos
who's my brother yeah hosting and
Gilbert went over and over again and
said this horrible heinous thing can i
play this for go ahead go ahead
but it's horrible
[Music]
[Music]
this opens up a lot of stuff that we
need to back out because for one this
couldn't be done right now right and if
it was it wouldn't be televised and it's
the least funny thing on the earth you
know there's nothing more heinous than
rape on the earth and people should be
I'm not here to put sentences on people
yeah but Gilbert is a love and I love
Gilbert Gottfried
so Gilbert Godfried when Gilbert says
the worst thing in the world he is just
literally saying this is the worst thing
in the world so he's saying it as a
statement but what he's saying is this
is there's nothing worse than this so
I'm gonna say it a hundred times but so
far I haven't seen you provide any
evidence to the contrary and I don't
intend to in 1990 where was I oh I was
now it all clicks no see the first thing
is this and I've talked about this with
several people I've never ever been a
guy who I mean if I wanted somebody's
number when I was I'm divorced 22 years
ago I was I got divorced I did like six
girlfriends and now I'm finally with the
person that is like a dream for me I'm
happy for you like we get to talk we get
to be together and and and everything is
just I mean it's I miss her I mean I'd
much rather be with her than you right
oh I don't blame you she's gone so I
mean but she'll be back but right after
this but what happened is you know you
make mistakes but mistakes I would have
made my that I made in my life would
have been alcohol induced but I'm never
ever I don't have the ability the way I
was raised
and who I am to forcibly put myself on
someone ever I might have tried to kiss
somebody by moving toward them like
second grade well not a tongue down is
really not a holding someone forcibly so
yeah most I will have find out repulsive
hostage I would have to have someone
like Bob Costas no I would I'd have to
have someone but wearing a Kosta shirt
Mecosta right no I would need to go to
la Costas and you San Diego where we
aristocrats based artists free
associations Crazy Eights good words do
you understand that yes eight of clubs
so you then you have to bring up a clubs
here an eight you think I'm having a
break I thought it was just no I'm just
saying the formula of improv Oh
but anyway well I think you have to be
you have I don't tell you the truth is I
do not like when I read on Twitter you
know like people that repeat what
Gilbert said because it's out of context
alright and it's out of context with you
knowing Gilbert at seven god I think
that was part of that that was what was
the job that was the joke Dan and the
roast that lasted it's a real you know
it was so funny cuz greg Giraldo and I
loved him and he passed away and it
sucks yeah and he was the first person
up and so I'm sitting there and I'm
thinking what have I done oh my god
because he said that I look like with
those granny glasses and that pointy
beaky nose you look like the Vlasic
pickles store and I'm like oh god what's
gonna happen to me now and then some of
the producer announced over the
loudspeaker tell Bob to look comfortable
right that's helpful and then it got it
got easier I started to figure it out
the nor McDonald got up and my friends
got up norm did the bit where he just
read from a joke book yeah that was and
I had told him that was the curse and
then he finally did yeah I'm saying
[ __ ] dog face okay yeah yeah but but
the point is you know people try to stay
self about you but thank goodness that's
from a kiss glamour Bob Saget as far as
we know has not raped or murdered any
females not as far as that
take that prize how can I know I'm not I
don't know everything look you said it
150 times
everybody here is debatable to me
indicates that Bob has committed no such
crime it is never happened except
through the mouth of Gilbert Godfrey yes
and I have also been through the mouth
of Gilbert God incidentally because you
I mean he's like three and a half feet
short it's just both I went to dinner
with Cobra and I said what happened to
you is it what happened every year did
you have a rough life well you wanna see
where your parents in the Holocaust tell
me the truth we had an honest dinner and
anyone nope I said then why I did it on
his podcast because everybody's
grandmother has a podcast yeah there's a
lot of pot but you guys have rung out of
the desert like Israel my trees there I
mean I bought a lot of trees as a kid
are they there that's a good question
where are all the trees you see a little
forest with maggots little sag trees
yeah I got at least 10 to the bar mitzva
what if there's just a giant scheme that
they're just yeah when you get Bar
Mitzvahs Americans you there like like
Bitcoin hey we planted ten trees in
Israel in your honor and I mean at the
age of thirteen it's like yeah but who
[ __ ] cares
the north is it's not desert at all yeah
how could that has to because it's a
desert but I don't understand the theory
of Masada I don't understand it
mrs. get really really hey wait Masada
was that the thing were they the wrong
has killed all the Jews no that's where
they killed themselves before the Romans
crash right right right
you don't understand why they did it I
believe you I believe you fight to the
end I don't believe you kill yourself if
I guess what they did is they killed the
children and the females because they
didn't want them to be slaves and raped
and and they would have thrown the
babies off the mountainside I raped all
the women so they're like I'd rather
take your life well you make a good
point
probably letting the brother end on a
really positive note oh I'm not leaving
now I was going to say you've got you've
gotta get Tommy you're gonna okay I'm
not gonna no we're great
I'm canceling everything masada can we
get some images in people of images that
you have a shoe of a movie out I haven't
sought out are in the movie that's gonna
come out in the summer and it's called
Benjamin and I worked seven years on it
one Nicholas at a Barak and a writer
Joshua Turek brought it to me and said
are you interested and I went I love
this story and it's about participation
I am the director and an actor and an
craite I I was we had a very low budget
and a very short shoot only 15 days and
I played the dad of a kid played by max
Burkholder who was on the show
Parenthood really good actor and we
think he's on crystal meth so it's based
on something that isn't relevant and
important and my girlfriend played by
the very talented Mary Lynn rice cub she
posts on Facebook that we're gonna have
an intervention and I don't think that's
where you post an intervention right and
then the the band who leaves the
intervention is Rob Corddry the
hilarious Rob Corddry who's the family
gynecologist and it's got Kevin Pollak
and Cheri Oteri and Dave Foley and
medicine and Clara Mamet and it's about
a family and in less than 24 hours
trying to help this kid right but you
find out that and it's a dark comedy
obviously it's not a it's not a laugh
it's very masks entire cast and their
own lives at the end but I'm really
excited about it I'm excited people to
see it because I think it hits a lot of
notes of how screwed up relatives are
that coming to town and how people's
respect it I would say near the end of
the summer is the lime excited I can't
wait I don't think it's gonna be a lot
of a lot of enjoyment I'm not saying I
enjoy me and I and I think it has a
certain point you see to it
enter and that's why I made it and
that's my hope is that people will love
it well congratulations I'm that's
really exciting
I'm sure no small feat direct and
act in seven years seven years and if
you have small feet it doesn't
necessarily mean that you have a small
it doesn't change the feet itself if the
hands are the thing that if they're
small right but feet has it ever been
brought out that if you have small feet
you have small well the gag was always
you know what you say about people with
small feet
now all sucks oh really
that's brilliant little unexpected
little twist that's the cleanest and
most proud of me no [ __ ] particles no no
no particles there are partial particles
on socks because you are in the bathroom
in your socks generally you take a [ __ ]
the particles get on your socks so if I
could get a set your socks can I tell
you something though morning no I
showered before I came here I don't wear
socks on
there's [ __ ] better I [ __ ] in the socks
before I put them on I was more than I
bargained for I was backing out of the
house today to come here just basically
just moving backwards but in the car in
the car I was in Reverse in a car right
backing out and that's when a gardener
was trying to be helpful and put the
trash cans in the driveway cuz the gate
was closed he couldn't bring him in not
good and I had to get out of the car and
touch the garbage perils and bring him
in and that ruined my day
well you ruined my wash your hands after
that well we were leaving
ruin my whole day have you ever I drove
the car limb since I drove I had the
wheel like this right right good
airplane pilot you have not cleaned your
hands all over that Mike well I've been
in preparation for receiving your socks
now I cleaned them the minute I got here
oh you did yeah I'm gonna go touch the
valet guy when I leave yeah good pat on
the back all over his whole body it was
like the parking-lot Soup Nazi you
parked between those two things but that
thing looks like a truck from Star Wars
I don't want to park tech know that that
parking lot is a disaster it makes me
very nervous
what do you think about the idea of
bringing him up here and to do a little
gag on the show
necessary because I'm staying a little
longer I think not now just generally Oh
generally yeah when you could I mean the
Letterman Show always had the guy that
owned the deli next door right you got
your parking lot not see but but you
don't know what kind of germs he's got I
mean I would say that he is sick half
the year yeah I'm gonna cure that we'll
have two saran wrap him obviously I
guarantee you this week he ate was it
Top Ramen is that how you say it rahman
how do you how do you are rich no I've
never had it his tongue main how do you
say
ramen ramen men real I'm ignorant
there's a difference it sounds like what
like a an ivory tower oh person would
say Ramon oh well that's all we eat
that's all I was gonna say Top Ramen
it's great for me to bring up references
that I can't pronounce Top Ramen you've
never had Top Ramen I think I have it
was rated like monosodium glutamate back
in the day it was like powdered chicken
soup like if you eat this you have a
hundred percent chance of getting cancer
early that's how I feel and I still but
if you get in a good restaurant if
you're gonna that's why I love it right
good ramen is good that's great and then
you have a spoon and chopsticks so you
get very busy I still need the one that
cause makes me forget about ever just
that really and you pull back the top
it's been married about five years been
together for over ten that's really
really nice thank you thank you
you got married young yeah we were like
26 or 27 I did that I got married at 26
not to say that you'll be divorced in 14
years what team that's a long time to be
together
it's a look what I'm just curious after
being married for 14 years was the
divorce a gradual thing or was it all
like it's very painful
anybody that's listening who his parents
have been through it or their
grandparents but usually their parents
or or themselves if you do have any
adults listening yeah
not adults older people that have been
married I known even look at a
four year old as a kid I I I'm not an
aegis like it's really weird like I'll
have a long conversation with like a
nine year old people would be scared I'm
like I'm not Lenny from mice and men I'm
not gonna hurt them just talking it
again but it's it's a hard thing to go
through and if you cannot do it it'd be
great to work it out it just it happens
it happens and you know every
relationship has a time on it and it
could be forever it could be your whole
life if you're lucky you think it just
expired
I think it changed I think I changed you
were going through a lot I'm sure it's a
lot of stuff happened I thought I lost
two sisters and Wow
but that doesn't matter that's my stuff
she went through a lot you know it's
really hard you guys changed that's what
happened we we we I probably changed
more because she was pretty much solid
as a mom and stuff but um it's just hard
it's just hard and and people make
mistakes and and you can get through
those mistakes that's the other thing if
people are thinking of breaking up some
people stay together for the kids yeah
and and then the kids see a lot of
unhappiness right right and some people
are amazing and they're able to stay
together and they stay together but I'm
really I'm crazy fortunate I'd love to
freeze this moment just with you guys
right now Andy [ __ ] particles would be
frozen and like in the matrix neo was
dodging bullets
but my kids are so smart but it was just
really difficult but I'm friends with my
ex-wife and we you know we've raised
these three amazing women they're
they're women and I was trying to give
it to myself because they can't believe
it now what are they
31:28 lost their ballot all right yeah
yeah yeah and and we I'm gone to New
York I'm a month Fallon on on Tuesday
and my daughters and I have been texting
all day you know what do you want to eat
after this no I can't eat the night
before I'll be bloated you know daddy
gets bloated so the next night I can get
bloated time i bloat
Mika's interference I need to learn
about your boat so it's all about if
you're on camera to stop eating no well
that's but I probably like food I feel
that every day and I use it for solace
and they had a lot of us do I'm you know
there's things we love to eat what's
your favorite comfort food
I think old men I'm a cannibal and I
really enjoy cooking and eating an old
man so okay well we have evidence
mounting the accusations are starting to
look bad well now they're the ones about
the girl are wrong just me and my dad
was 89 and I loved him he was delicious
[Music]
I'm not saying I would do anything that
hurts any woman any person I would never
throw myself at anybody but if he's
there and he's still fresh right why not
cook him it's it's harmless you love it
it's what they call a victimless crime
right right so why not eat them sure
exactly
was there anything I we we well I am on
tour yeah you're going to tell us man
you just hit here's the normal website
with my name on it
Saget calm its si GE T in case people
want to spell it wrong and hurt my
feelings what's the common misspelling
on Saget well it rhymes with stuff so I
had a rough childhood say that to you
yes sir that's unbelievable I lived in
Norfolk Virginia
that's unbelievable no you would say it
because you spent an hour and a half on
[ __ ] particle you can't say you can say
that word I feel [ __ ] I'm holding on to
[ __ ] that way I think you should just
hold on to her and wipe the word from
your vocabulary except it's a dog a
female or male that you have Bonanza
mail okay so we can't use that nope
all right well maybe get another dog or
have a daughter and just cover that
important to me by the way I don't walk
around the house saying at all this is
the first time we're discussing our
intervention
this is this is an intervention where
the next time I see you guys might be on
the way to having a kid I hope so well
you should get started so I can come
back in nine months you want to come
back in nine months all right it's all
for you and she's ready to adapt you
bring me in I'll deliver the damn thing
I don't want you in that room I'm sure
of it I decided minutes what do you
think whatever the doctors say that Bob
can come in and you cannot the doctors
like this is a complicated birth we need
the only one man who can deliver this
baby the father from full house Bob
Saget will not so I'm on tour and that's
it that's all hey just thanks I'm out
I'm doing my studies and I'm doing
Denver cent on San Jose coming up then
Denver and Phoenix and I'm just staying
on the west coast for a little bit so
they're going to New York you know to do
Fallon on Tuesdays come on guys listen
good luck it's very important that you
follow these instructions go to Amazon
and watch the zero-to-sixty
it's extremely funny you're gonna love
it go to Bob sack accom buy some goddamn
tickets and see this Bob Saget in person
cuz you're gonna love it
it was been a Joyce but a pleasure has
been a lot of fun if the stand-up is
half as good as the special it's gonna
be the best night you've ever had so
please support this man and the film
we're all waiting for it yeah well when
it comes out even sooner we're gonna let
everyone know thank you all but I'll be
back and hold myself out in here yeah
it'll be around when you say the film's
out well I made you a lot July probably
so what month is it where are we I know
it's a sixteenth yesterday was the Ides
of March at Shakespeare he's that's
scary he's a little dude that wrote just
a little guy just a little dude a big
dream all right thank you for having me
you guys
[Music]
lucky you know yeah I know don't mess
this up
now you sound like my mom yeah I am your
mom and don't worry and I'm lactating so
it's yes okay all right do you mind yeah
it's almost like I've been drinking so
much that my milk will put you right to
bed
that's special you are good at breasts I
hope are our paths cross again thank you
well they will I mean I came here I had
a good time if you'll have me back out
on car yeah it's really hope our paths
will cross again well I don't know sound
like some movie I'm being dramatic
I'm being dramatic no you're wonderful
go god I'm late and everything like I'll
chill about it but I really enjoyed this
I could sit and do this for hours so I
understand how you can do it for hours
but I don't know how you can do it for
hours without me yeah it's impossible
those are 10 minutes we would keep going
but I know you have some stuff you have
to get it I have to go I have to meet a
writer immediately thank you for even
making the time in car thank you next
Saturday is our next episode the podcast
with Sean
Evans you're good I like him tell him
you have any like curses or you have
anything you want me to throw in his
eyes tell him there's nothing too hot he
can give me oh you're ready because we
have I I wanted to torture him because
he never shows he never shows suffering
on that show it's a little deceptive
because and I'm not judging the guy
though he takes a little nibbles oh he
takes tiny little ones it was like this
he does he's just a head shake but he
does but like the guest goes in because
you don't know like oh just take a
little nibble and there the difference
when a little nibble and a big bite is
the whole world yeah so I'm in again I
was I was eating the whole wing I know I
saw that's what he died I know
like if I was who nobody could go the
whole wing every time he takes a little
nibble yeah and that's what he should
burn it oh wow
but in Saturday we're gonna get him
number one you watch so guys thank you
so much for tuning we'll see you next
Saturday
god bless ya appreciate you stay good be
good watch over the ship particles wash
your hands regularly and Joey enjoy your
weekend thank you guys see you next time